this episode brought to you by
experienced increase your credit score
instantly by taking back control
[Music]
hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic guy
remember it so you don't have to let's
talk about one of my favorite movies of
all time Mary Poppins no let's not
because why there's nothing I can say
about how awesome this movie is that
millions of people haven't said already
it's a masterpiece of beautifully
matched contradictions it's colorful and
obvious yet dark and mysterious
it's energized and happy yet slow-moving
and patient it has one of the worst fake
accents of all time coming out of one of
the most likable characters of all time
it has some of the best songs ever
written son by some of the best
performances ever given so much money
effects care and effort from two polar
opposite creative geniuses for an
innocent little kids story Fred Rogers
used to say it seems better to be deep
and simple than shallow and complex this
movie seems like the definition of deep
and simple a one of a kind mashing that
can never be duplicated but because we
like to reward Disney slumming it let's
try anyway
MARY POPPINS returns is the latest in a
long line of unnecessary Disney sequel
slash reboots you might be wondering
what which one is it sequel or reboot
fear not it's such that both made 54
years after the original premiered this
was an attempt to recapture the magic
and fresh ideas of the timeless classic
I guess it's not a complete loss of an
idea after all there were more Mary
Poppins books there was even a hit
Disney Broadway musical that had the
author P L Travers overseeing the
production
don't worry though it doesn't try any of
those smart ideas it instead tries to
continue the story with a brand new tale
that somehow does the exact same thing
the original did except bad and stupid
and bad well I'm not accepting any Mary
Poppins that isn't practically perfect
in every way that's why I'm calling in
some very special help
subtly beautiful music that can only
mean
[Music]
hello mr. critic hello
MARY POPPINS fix your posture we're not
sloths sorry Mary Poppins there's a good
boy right I hear someone smearing my
good names yes right in there all right
let's go spit spots where she sits best
pillow
[Music]
oh they think they're being unique by
changing the logo again you know if you
do that too many times it's just not
unique anymore is it no Mary Poppins
let's change that right up
[Music]
Wow first we'll put the logo back to the
way it originally was you don't have to
rely on cheap gimmicks when you're
actually good or practically perfect in
every way right now yeah cool
now what's this when Manuel sings a song
about lighting arms and then it cuts two
paintings behind the opening credits
well that's peculiar shouldn't it be the
other way around so that it flows better
why I suppose it would come on Mary
Poppins you really do fix everything
gracious what is that sounds like an
annoyingly dumb-down score that's
confused for windsor huh that can only
mean
[Music]
how'd you get here I've always been here
now where is that dreadful music
hello Mary fit is it Poppins 2.0 I
understand you want to change our Disney
formula
hey hey you stay out of this reboot
quill we're trying to fix what you
botched up a lot of things have changed
since you last showed up Mary Disney is
more powerful than you could possibly
imagine
powerful enough to steal from Star Wars
we own Star Wars oh very impressive Hey
we don't care how much you own you can't
recapture the magic of dancing Chimney
Sweeps
tea parties on ceilings and snapping to
get a job well done oh well now in
Disney when you snap your fingers
something very different happens no
don't do it well she was practically
boring in every way she was a timeless
treasure oh please she was from the 60s
children have no interest in seeing
anything from an age with no cell phones
she needs an update and I am that update
you I have no idea what children want
we're Disney we tell them what they want
Dumbo Aladdin Sleeping Beauty or replace
my dear boy
mmm it feels so skirt
you can't just don't race these timeless
classics like they never existed
I already have now get on with the
review and don't try to alter the Disney
formula because if you do have a lovely
ashtray with your name on it
spit-spot
[Music]
this is doing improved as mentioned
before a Semite bert named jack played
by lin-manuel miranda sings a song about
being a Lamplighter
oh god is the birth lady dead that's a
happy start I'm still feeding the birds
just with my lifeless corpse since you
dream the night away tomorrow you it's
cold today honestly the one thing I
loved in this movie that weirdly gets a
lot of flack is the songs yes they're
heavily mimicking the lyrics and
melodies from the original even down to
the same order they're being played but
it's likely that's what composer Marc
Shaiman was asked to do give us another
chim chiminey give us another
supercalifragilistic and so on it's
stupid that Disney wanted an imitation
instead of something new but with that
said they are good imitations clearly
familiar but still clever and hummable
even if some of the singers go Michael
Crawford on the last note
[Music]
he's turning into Kevin McCallister from
home alone too
[Music]
his bird lady is still alive - no segue
whatsoever we're given the opening
credit which clearly should have looked
like this don't get me started on how
popping should've looked as we see like
in the first one the bank's home in
disarray that classic problem we see
Jane and Michael have grown up with
Michael looking after the house with his
three children boy number one boy number
two and girl I call them that because
they have so little personality it's not
even worth mentioning their names for
you to forget literally any of their
lines could be switched out with the
other sibling and it wouldn't make a
difference well we have grown up a good
deal in the past year after all oh now
wait a minute I'm pretty sure that's a
boy number two line well now that seems
out of character that's clearly
something girl would say wow that's such
a character inconsistency it's you're
right for the final season of Game of
Thrones topical boys from the bank show
up though saying Michaels house is in
danger of being repossessed she took out
a loan with fidelity fiduciary back
against the value of your home not
enough these days isn't it yes well yes
so I hope you enjoy a lot of bank talk
with no songs it's just a mere ten
minutes of seat squirming boredom your
kids have to get through the bank is now
demanding that you pay back the entire
looms piling up I really had no choice
you have fallen three months behind I
work for fidelity fiducial alters an
account it's all in the contract two
shares in the shares certificate
document proving your own shares if you
are unable to pay in full about
comparing interest rates and cost of
property well they just my dear
something you'll know as quickly as the
movie has no momentum the first one
opened with a lot of talking inside the
house - but he was active funny moving
with songs dance numbers even though
they were talking about stuff kids would
find boring they made it entertaining
hear what they're talking about is
boring and it feels boring the only
movement we get is emerald boom played
this time by David Warner setting off
his cannon rockin the house which we've
already seen done a lot better the first
time they did it even when we do finally
get a song it's
hello downer song which doesn't feel
earned because we've already been
watching ten minutes of slow down her
stuff winter has come but not in both
versions Poppins arrives around the same
time in fact it's eerie how close it is
but this version feels so much longer
maybe if there was something new or
challenging being talked about that
would make up for a little bit but we
have a bank that wants to take away
their home a trope so old it's in the
three stooges game three interchangeable
kids seem perfectly well-behaved and get
along with their dad isn't that exciting
new territory and apparently there's a
dead mother which we have never ever
ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever
ever ever ever ever ever ever seen
before
so clearly all the slow-moving TD on
this warranted why on earth did we save
this old broken thing father made it the
night he almost offed himself ah good
memories when Poppins does finally show
up even that's a little weird the kite
flies away and one of the kids chases
after it but the music sounds less like
a magical friend is about to appear and
more like the Empire is gonna blow up
planet Earth
[Music]
point eating tree you will have no more
child skeletons in your branches but
Kate though is retrieved by Poppins
played by Emily Blunt after robbing
agent Carter's wardrobe at gunpoint
you need to be more careful when the
wind rises George you nearly lost your
kite wait the little boy's name is
Georgie well we all know what really
should have been at the end of that
string Georgie I was just your age and
we first met working for a chimney sweep
how is dear old bird Savin the world is
off two points unknown he's high isn't
he every day his family is clearly in
desperate need of a nanny now quick
March and best foot forward now thank
you not to daughter so remember kids
when two strangers say they're going to
force their way into your life and home
it's best just to go with it what if I
told you better good evidence no from
the other place as you can tell from
this creepy beer shot seriously just
replace it with horror music it's kind
of terrifying you know that her she's
checking herself out mmm that is
Britain's off's Blount is honestly
pretty good as Poppins and really to be
fair most of the actors do a good job
with what they're given but the
motivations rarely make sense for
example Poppins says this they've come
to look after the banks children yes you
too obviously indicating she's mainly
there to help Michael and Jane but she
almost never talks to them maybe the
idea is through the kids she helps them
out by making them better people but the
kids seem fine
I dare even say so unoffensive they
never make an impact on us that's so boy
number two wouldn't it make more sense
if the kids were more like adults taking
care of things and Mary Poppins has to
teach them how to have fun again thus
forcing Michael to act more like an
adult I mean we see a second of
something like that starting with the
kids calling the plumber and running an
errand later but that's about it
if there are other scenes they're not
properly explored meaning there isn't
enough to give them a proper identity or
even what should be the main conflict of
the film budget
identity why not really flesh them out
so this makes more sense did someone say
this films not practically perfect in
every way
yeah you start off with good ideas but
never follow all the way through why
don't you make the kids - bratty or too
sophisticated you don't give him an arc
because that would go against the Disney
formula what the children was simple and
likeable in the first film so now it's
part of the Disney formula will give you
forever
well you're not shoving that Disney
formula down my poo recycle plop
unimaginative story rushed script you
know just because you make crappy new
ones doesn't mean we'll forget how good
the originals are oh dear is someone
ready to snap no I'm good
lovely I've got my eye on you critic
spit-spot
I have a scared of Poppins Mary gives
the kids a bath and a musical number
that's honestly fine it's not as brow
breaking as some of the other numbers
and the original Poppins but it's still
a good song with some nice visuals hey
this really is Batman Returns
when does the penguin by George ease
nose the only thing kind of odd is
despite blunt doing a pretty good acting
job and not just an imitation of Andrews
her sternness is well played but her
smiling moments usually seem off
something about Andrews pulled off both
strict scenes and delighted scenes so
perfectly blunt always looks like she's
gonna kill someone whenever she smiles
it's never quite believable also you
totally missed a Jack Sparrow cameo
licking his own brain in front of a
hanging little boy afterwards the kids
tried to tell Michael about their
adventures but he's upset because he
can't find the shares his father put
away to help them in case a financial
crisis like this happened I don't need
to be crossed with all of you I I've
just lost something very important oh
this is gonna be symbolic of how they
lost a family member and how their
anxiety over the finances are really
tied to or we don't do that could've
really explored something meaningful
there and found unique ways to deal with
loss let's do it as much easier just to
say one bad guy is causing all your
problems
who'd have thought this slump would be
so good for business then Colin Firth
plays a snobby British bad guy imagine
as Jayden Michael tried to ask for proof
of their stock but it seems he can't
locate it guess what kids more banked
hard body extensions a little I can do a
father did leave us shares in the band
you wouldn't happen to have any record
of fathers shares would you doesn't seem
to be a listing for George banks here
bringing all of George banks his old
files would you okay the other poppins
film had the bank as a boring place to
but it was entertaining ly boring
cleverly boring there were songs there
was choreography there were funny
characters it was fun to watch as a
child even if you didn't know the
details
what they were talking about this one is
long-winded slow and no kid in the right
mind would follow it in the first film
you get it Michael wants his money to
feed the birds and his father wants him
to put it away done easy no kid would be
able to follow any of this boring as
helll technical talk tell me which one
of these a kid or even an adult for that
matter would probably prefer watching
[Music]
bringing the shareholders ledger would
you miss funny mr. Dores jr. he'd never
father as he chairs with me dear old
uncle doors is getting on in years sadly
that's why I had to take over for oh
sorry I am died for a minute Mary
Poppins on top of that there's a big
difference between a villain and an
antagonist in the first film the bank is
the antagonist here it's the villain the
bank in the first movie is not evil they
think they're doing good by helping
Michael invest the idea is Michael is
too young to be thinking of things like
that he should be allowed to still be a
kid and spend what little he has on
something ethical learning morality is
the most important at that age then when
he's a little older he can start saving
up with the responsibility of knowing
what's truly important mr. banks isn't
evil he just lost track of what's
important even mr. Dawes isn't evil he
could have just taken the kids money by
force but he waits for him to open his
hand trying to convince Michael if he
handed it over he's sneaky but he
doesn't think he's doing wrong this guy
clearly knows he's doing wrong crumpling
up the proof that can save Michael's
house and burning it so here's our
chance to get that house I don't like to
lose mr. Frye yeah whatever problems
you're going through don't try to
understand it by seeing things from a
different point of view it's just a bad
guy out there you're just good he's just
bad and any soul-searching about
understanding others that could bring
people closer together blow that shit
it's just bad guys problem solved was
this a classic again oh because they
didn't happen us versus
mentality stupid mature crap Lorax was a
hit you idiots bad guy it is I mean it's
practically perfect in every way
snap hello jack you know Burt told me
about you always friend-zoning right the
kids accidentally break a ceramic ball
that could possibly be sold to get money
for the house hey why don't you start by
selling those kids robes you don't need
Christ half the stuff in this mansion
could probably pay off two houses it's a
well-known fact ceramic bowls sound like
1920s radio time to do the sidewalk
thing now tread lightly this is fine
porcelain and we don't want to chip the
glaze it's a chamber pot too so it might
wreak like Georgie's bedsheets Seamus
oh the Irish dog would be more than
happy to drive the English whatever they
like
where's the music-hall
I blew it up they wanted a cover charge
so I covered them in ashes it is nice to
see hand-drawn animation again and the
design is very cleverly mixing the three
dimensions of the bowl with the two
dimensions of the paintings but again
we've already seen this it's a bowl
instead of a sidewalk okay what else
nothing has ever upped in this movie
aside from the technology which as I
said before is good but not
groundbreaking like the original don't
wait there is one change and big
surprise it's such ceramic balls
apparently even the fantasy world has
bad guys in it yeah that's a thing now
very long now get yourself some peanuts
and candy floss
okay this is like the Fox from the
merry-go-round scene suddenly being like
to genetic engineering around us I have
plans for you
ironic because they sing a song called
the cover is not the book I guess that
just means if they look like bad guys
they really are bad guys
Oh God is Mary gonna do a striptease
I've seen her spoon for Oh sugar it fed
me Birds the director of Chicago you say
this is followed by oh let's just say
where it is the Lynn Manuel song
Hamilton Hamilton Hamilton Hamilton that
elephant is giving me the dead ice why
do I have the characters in this look
like they want to slit my throat
I have plans for you speaking of which
the real threats show up as Georgie
notices the wolf is stealing parts of
their room and yes I know I said it
wasn't gonna name the kids because
they're forgettable but come on his name
is Georgie and part two is coming out
the comedy police could arrest me for
not referencing that well well if it
isn't the boy who cracked the boat who
cried wolf the obvious bad puncher don't
go far
time to go boys you're going to work in
the blood diamond mines your new name is
one six five four
MARY POPPINS everybody isn't this what
you think of when you envision a multi
Academy Award winning movie actually who
knows now when I see the jolly holiday
songbirds sung to Mary I have to wonder
if during that the kids were fighting
off vampire penguins I have to seriously
consider that now honey badger don't
give a shit
[Music]
welcome to hell children if you feel
something uncomfortable that's just the
everlasting damnation of your soul they
all wake up as apparently it was a dream
they all shared I like that too so did I
it seemed awfully real famous mother who
oh right there's a dead mother in this
van bobbin sings a nice song about
remembering their mom which is
definitely needed because I think this
is the first time the kids even bring up
missing her and we're halfway through
the movie it would have been nice if
there was more focus on both the kids
and Michael missing her and trying to
bond as a family to get through it but
we need to focus on more important
things like psychotic kidnapping wolves
and document burning bankers you know
relatable stuff apologies but despite
your complaints most critics agree this
film is wonderful what impossible ready
let's see how this film measures up
80% on Rotten Tomatoes really now let's
see how you measure up
cynical check yes who hates new things
I don't hate new things I hate lazy
things I wish there was more new things
in this but the stuff that's kept the
same is so emotionally empty and the
stuff that's and it is so unrelatable
and cliched it's not that it's new and
smart it's that it's acting like it's
new and smart oh come now
we're the best of both worlds we're like
a Disney reboot and a Disney sequel both
of those Disney does infamously bear
millions at the box office doesn't my
constant critical praise doesn't lie but
does that mean that gives you an excuse
for fast lazy writing you forget critic
we're Disney we're perfect in every way
what happened to practically I snapped
it out of existence would you like
another demonstration no I'm good very
well enjoy the rest of what Mary Poppins
is now and will forever be
[Music]
I don't believe in spooks I do believe
in spooks I do I do I do believe in
spooks I do
[Applause]
[Music]
things things and things I want things
how many things Oh may I have your
credit card sir number number number
number number number number number sorry
your credit is not good enough for all
four things what I've always had great
credit how did this happen you should
have used Experian boost me matey
Pru Experian is empowering consumers to
increase their credit scores instantly
people can now get credit for the good
behavior they have already been
exhibiting for paying utility and phone
bills they're already paying on time
Experian can do this I didn't know that
it's all because of Experian bust
Experian boast is a game-changing
product that puts consumers in control
and if that wasn't enough it's also
surely let me try that rolling all again
for it sounds like experience mission is
to boost American credit score so that
millions of Americans can have better
credit yeah Experian boost works by
giving you credit for the utility and
telecom bills you're already paying so
if your pite bills like water gas
electric cable cell phone through our
checking or savings accounts you could
instantly raise your credit score that
sounds like a game-changer it truly is
this is the first time a credit bureau
is allowing consumers to submit utility
and telecom payments to be factored into
their credit file those not even on and
only Experian is doing this this is also
the first time credit scores can be
raised instantly most people who boost
increase their scores by more than 10
points PMI a pirate or Scottish now it
sounds like this is a way to take back
control it is and only positive payments
will be factored into your credit file
it can only help you not hurt you my god
of cameras watching me in rare
situations while a person's score goes
down from boosting they can instantly
disconnect boost and their credit score
will go right back to where it was you
literally have nothing to lose should I
tell them how it could help me do that
my credits usually pretty good but with
something like this it can not only keep
my credit score at a great place but it
make it even better well done Lassie I
am NOT a dog Sally tell them how they
can get it here's how you get reduced
it's only available at Experian come
slash nostalgia that expe Rin the combs
/ nostalgia why would anyone not want to
make their credit better I don't know
I'm just you as a pilot deed you are
I like pencils experiences can
potentially help you establish or
increase your access to credit boost
your score instantly and free by going
to Experian comm / nostalgia that's exp
er I am calm / nostalgia yard pixels
you
hey Doug Walker here letting you know
some of the conventions we have coming
up from June 7th to 9th is indy popcon
in indianapolis and you can get a
discount out tickets if you just use the
promo code awesome when purchasing them
from June 21st to the 23rd we have
planet bunk in Iowa this is our first
time at this one and sure to be a lot of
fun and from July 6 to 7th its Salt City
Comic Con at the New York State
Fairgrounds in Syracuse New York we have
even more conventions this year but
these are the ones coming up so go to
the sites get the tickets drop on by and
say hi would love to see you
[Applause]
so Poppins and the kids tried to visit
someone who can fix the bowl
Jack offers them a ride in a you know as
good as the songs are in this movie the
musical score is freaking obnoxious
dancing on a bike can be kind of neat
but after breathing under the ocean in
your bathtub talking with animals and
almost getting killed by monopoly Balto
this really doesn't warrant ooh whoa the
whimsy music but you know that be subtle
and Mary Poppins it's just a dumb thing
for kids you're not supposed to get that
involved lamp here we are
well place your bets entrance to
Hogwarts Wonderland or Chocolate Factory
No what the oh whoa I was wrong is the
entrance to a Meryl Streep performance
not trying to get an Oscar was a rare my
whole world goes flippity-flop like a
turtle on his back
well one way or another we're doing a
song in the ceiling and at the exact
same point is the album of all you're
used to that by now
and I don't know my up from my down my
east from my vest my top C from my
bottom is it me or does she look like
one of the in-between makeups from mrs.
Doubtfire anything I tried to fix on
second Wednesday those Kim fluey
I am so offended on behalf of the
nationality of whatever accent she's
doing so they sing a song about seeing
things from a different point of view
again this is like the fourth song that
sings about that you know what's ironic
you're always singing about seeing
things differently when you're
essentially telling the exact same movie
again
my head you know perhaps if the room
kept spinning or the house flew over the
neighborhood or something like that
that'd be kind of cool but this really
doesn't seem that magical because it's
just an upside-down room they prance
around in that's it a set that's cool
for about two seconds and then they just
kind of run around in circles
that's a carnival funhouse not magical
whimsy the cousin says she'll try to fix
the bowl as Poppins and the kids run an
errand at the bank because we're at that
part of the movie now they follow the
two lawyers - the big bad banker who
discusses his evil scheme maniacal laugh
you are not giving banks one more second
to pay off that loan yes as the song
goes the cover is not the book which way
to dream about a cartoon wolf who held a
watch a certain way in which case judge
the hell out of that person because you
had a dream about it
it's just facts full-stop what would
even do it be caught them let's trap
them to the banks here no children burst
into my office just seeing if anything
can be done about extending your loan
when they came in claiming I was trying
to steal your house I believe they're
also communist of course Michael doesn't
believe them as the big bad banker
subtly threatens them god these are such
emotional problems we can all identify
with no you don't broke bones I didn't
even know I had what time is it oh it's
get lost in the dark and calorie-free
Burke comes along to make everyone feel
better with his pals o'clock with me
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen and even crappier
version of Newsies
okay so if we're supposed to they go wow
this is justice match goes the first
time they did it let's really compare
the two at this point in the movie it's
a rush of energy stunts and music it's
clearly a set but it doesn't feel that
way it's dancing on rooftops with all
sorts of various shots and effects that
make it feel like a whole wide world
that you've never seen has been opened
up to you it's an incredible moment you
wish would never end
this looks claustrophobic it looks like
a set and it feels like a set it's
choreographed like a stage show as
opposed to a movie which for something
like Chicago is fine as it's a movie
about stage shows but with Mary Poppins
you want to feel like something grander
is being offered you want step in time
to keep going switching from one cool
location to the next
here you just feel trapped like a school
that dragged you to a children's play
that brought in BMX bikers because the
young kids are into that right we're in
the first one you never wanted it to end
this one you just want it to stop so we
can move on to the next scene you're
ripping off from the first movie oh the
magic yeah what have you been speaking
of which they find their way home as
Michael yells at them for nearly costing
him his job and you Mary Poppins I
thought you were here to look after
these children it wasn't hard doing it
was me
no it was us way to throw Georgie under
the bus
Michael has a meltdown talking about all
that's right a dead wife that's still a
thing right
[Music]
the kids sing the song Poppins sunk to
them earlier once again taking on the
parental role proving there is no art
for them as they were hinting they had
the parental role before and even that
they didn't do much of so I have no idea
how any of these characters are supposed
to have changed oh wait maybe they
spontaneously beat it into me whole time
I've been looking after them they've
been looking off to me something so felt
by the audience we had to spell it out
for you so I guess Michael learns that
the kids were helping him
did he not think that things seem
chaotic but his connection with the kid
seemed fine
is he gonna focus on getting his life
more organized nothing indicates that he
still works the same job and seems like
the same person by the end mr. banks in
the original learns that being young and
full of life is precious and he should
let his children live that life while
they still can well the children learned
that though he's not perfect their
father works hard and provides for them
and they should learn to appreciate and
respect that everyone here learns that
family is good which they already knew
and bankers are bad boo Disney we used
to be good at this
so they pack up the house and plan to
live at jeans but wait a moment one of
the papers sure to use to patch up his
kite is just the proof of shares they
need to keep the house well clearly Mary
Poppins can just use her flying umbrella
to take it to the back what's the time
anyone midnight seven minutes isn't
enough time I need to be at the bank by
midnight magic umbrella take the van
no good you still wouldn't make it in
time Matt chick umbrella don't we gather
the lyrics what Jones or not we ready to
bicycle mad chick I'm Brad you haven't
written the bicycle like this before
please have different gonna be from
riding an elephant I think that's a song
we missed but magic umbrella this is why
you stupid bad guy plot doesn't work in
a world like this the threats were
emotional not physical but since they've
changed that now it makes no sense why
this 90s kidz film climax is taking
place I'm just waiting for black
vehicles and fruit carts to be dragged
out
[Music]
I just wanted to remind you on Colin
Firth back to the climate change let's
go fly a kite yeah I'm positive that
line was written to always be the start
of an action scene Mary Poppins you're
so back
you know it's funny the climax of the
original film is one of the most
emotional things I've ever seen it's
simply a man walking to his job about to
lose the majority of how he valued
himself it has no dialogue no action no
exciting music it's just a person
walking to the end of a major part of
his life thinking about what's most
important shit we need to turn back the
clocks it was a big bad bank your can
take away our house can them climb that
building Kermie are we are me two big
bad evil bang Wow suddenly I'm thinking
about what matters most to me evaluating
this eerie yet peaceful environment will
die hold dear and I should focus my time
towards somebody needs to grow up you
need to pull people into the air man the
kids going into big bed bag trying to
keep Jane and Michael from getting in to
save their home I mean what's this banks
looking at where the burn lady used to
be making him question what's most
important to life a profit or simple
pleasures suggesting that children
watching the film can handle complex
emotional ideas this is why people
forget you're a thing you need to type
to kick open the window so the big bed
bankers papers get go fun all over the
place and only the last minute does Mary
Poppins finally help by taking to the
air because she has a god damn why God
Briella
me what a bunch of dog shit I've been
watching all these years Mary Poppins
returns you're the update I've always
been waiting for Disney I bow to you no
seriously go to goddamn hello even after
all that it appears goddamn hell so even
after all that it appears it's still not
enough to save the house but mr. Dawes
jr. cleverly cast it with Dick Van Dyke
comes in saying he's taking control the
bank back and to leave the house alone
so when life's over your fish soup ah
you must choose to be
oh boy since still sucks but I can do
this even though I'm a million bitches
got nothing on me Michael wanted to give
his couplings to a bad lady he decided
to take it to his father Michael's
father gave those tuppence in this Bank
wait and after several quite clever
investment that tuppence has grown into
quite a tidy sum enough to pay off that
around you - ah I was canvassing mr.
banks give that money back to Michael I
mean it is still his money and he was
fired from that job - no he did the
exact opposite of what Michael wanted at
the time arguably defeating the entire
purpose of the movie now I guess the
moral is the bank is evil don't devote
your life to it but if other people
devote their life to it for you allowing
you to massively profit in the end
that's totally fine do you have any idea
how - movie movie the only one London's
supposed to get this year we get a
genuinely nice song and cameo from
Angela Lansbury presumably meant for
Julie Andrews but she was busy working
on Aquaman which was released the same
day and kicked its ass no easterlies it
is still a nice scene and a clever send
up to fly a kite because it actually ups
the visuals and the ideas like what the
rest of the movie should have been doing
Georgiy but is there any redemption for
our big bad banker nope well except for
you there's nowhere to go but hell cuz
you're the villain we're kind movie
poppins of course opens up her umbrella
and properly exits I won't forget Mary
Poppins please well I can never forget
the horrors that I witnessed
[Music]
hey pockets to point home where are you
it's a once I'm in my Hellfire okay I
want to be fair fair because there are
some decent things in this movie the
songs are good the acting is good some
of the visuals and ideas are a good
start oh good I'll add another percent
on Rotten Tomatoes but those ideas are
never fleshed out and are instead
replaced with a lazy lazy lazy script
and you can't be lazy with Mary Poppins
the original had dignity subtlety and a
surprising amount of restraint when you
now see what it could have been it will
be remembered always as a classic this
will be remembered as that movie you put
on to shut your kids up it's bright and
colorful and means very little despite
it trying to mean very much and as
movies like that go you can show it to
your kids fine keep them distracted for
a few hours but that's not what Mary
Poppins is supposed to do Mary Poppins
is supposed to entertain your inner
child but also challenge your inner
adult making you think hard about what's
important when it's important and why
it's important it was brought to us by
two people who believed in the story
just as much as they believed in the
kids they told the story too
this just feels like a corporate cash in
trying to recapture the magic because it
was still popular maybe we can do the
same thing again and make a couple bucks
for some those nostalgic fields will hit
close to home and if they do I can't
blame you you're gonna have an emotional
response to certain icons and Mary
Poppins is a very easy icon to get
emotional about but where that Mary
Poppins was truly something special this
Mary Poppins is just another kids movie
created not to be unique but just to
make money where the original was the
very definition of deep and simple this
is the very definition of shallow and
complex my dear little Hobgoblin do you
know what I do to people who talk to me
like that I don't care the movies are
trying to do reboots and sequels to
deserve better than what you're giving
them what a gigantic budget money means
nothing without caring and oh you
about is making money off of these
because they're popular even if you
don't understand why they may look like
the original characters and sound like
the original characters but poorly
copying what they did doesn't make them
the original characters it just makes
them a poor copy and for the sake of
those timeless characters you're trying
to replace I call bullshit and I call
upon the satanic powers of my snappy
fingers
MARY POPPINS the original Mary Poppins
oh yes your passion and remembrance
brought us all back us
Oh
Lion King
Jeannie
originals
oh you ain't never felt pain like this
[Music]
Chim Chim cheroo bitch
oh my god thank you all and because
you're such a pain animating I'm just
gonna talk to Mary right now that's fair
Oh
Mary it's so good to have you back well
as long as people like you never forget
I'll never to really be gone so true
don't agree with me too much no one
likes a suck-up so true and don't use
that same footage of you giving the same
honest answer
but Mary will you'll ever truly return
no but why would you want me to wasn't
what we already had practically perfect
in every way
as about sir
so long Mary Poppins don't stay away too
long now
I just said I'm never coming back until
we meet again what a dumbass
[Music]
hey Doug Walker here international
medical corpses this week's charity
shout-out this is a global nonprofit
humanitarian aid organization dedicated
to saving lives and relieving suffering
they do this by providing emergency
medical services as well as healthcare
training and development programs to
those in great need they're a private
group with no political or religious
affiliation their mission is to improve
the quality of life through health
interventions and related activities
that strengthen underserved communities
worldwide with the flexibility to
respond rapidly to emergencies no matter
where in the world they occur they offer
medical assistance and training to
people at the highest risk always
working to strengthen local health care
systems and promote self-reliance with
an A rating on charity watch this is a
group that works hard to help so many
people and you can play a part in their
mission click on the link and help those
who already helped so many
you